las obras del polémico gasoducto nord
stream 2 que une rusia y alemania- por
el fondo del mar báltico ya han
finalizado lo anunciado gazprom el
gigante energético ruso que lidera el
proyecto junto con otras empresas
europeas este proyecto se inició en
septiembre de 2018 y fue concebido para
diversificar las rutas de suministro de
gas y elevar la seguridad energética en
europa 900 aumentará la oferta de gas en
el continente justo en un momento en el
que los precios del combustible han
alcanzado máximos lo cual ha aumentado a
su vez los precios de la electricidad
tanto eeuu como algunos países de la
unión europea han mostrado durante años
su oposición a este proyecto porque
según ellos aumenta la dependencia
energética de rusia en detrimento de la
posición de ucrania esta infraestructura
cuya costa en cuya construcción ha
participado también compañías de
alemania austria francia o países bajos
consta de dos ramales de más de 1000
kilómetros para transportar hasta 55 mil
millones de metros cúbicos de
combustible al año